this was greenbelt until 2019
for more than 30 years susan's chilton's
home
looked out on the green belt but that
protection
has now been removed to allow
development and this view
may soon be replaced by housing they put
an outline plan
in now for 103 houses just in this space
how does that make you feel awful i know
people need housing
i'm not against development what i'm
against is where you
join up villages where you overcrowd
where there's no infrastructure we don't
have doctors we don't have school places
we don't have roads it takes you hours
to go anywhere
how can they possibly put houses and
then think about the infrastructure
afterwards
we can't even get potholes mended
concerns like these helped
trigger an unexpected political
earthquake in the chiltons this week
the liberal democrats winning a
by-election in cheshire and amisham
a previously rock-solid conservative
majority
undermined by concern this area of
outstanding natural beauty
is under threat from developers our
infrastructure cannot cope
with large-scale development
and um people have moved to this
area because green space is uh open air
um and they don't want to see it just it
expanded into a further suburb of london
there were specific local issues here
but senior conservatives are warning
concerns over planning reform
are a national problem the concern in
places like this
and across the south east is government
plans to automatically grant planning
permission
in certain areas of the country and to
reduce
residents opportunities to object the
target
is to build 300 000 new homes every year
last year they managed just 240 000
it's an issue in winchester 2 a
conservative held
lib dem target where this 77 home
development has gone ahead despite
objections offering much needed social
housing
i think it's terrible there's a lot of
free space outside of winchester and
outside of a lot of the cities and towns
where
you could utilize that free space quite
well i mean the towns have become quite
saturated
the traffic's always so heavy and it's
become quite overpopulated but where
there's so much space on the outskirts
it doesn't seem to make sense
that you wouldn't build housing that was
available to people on the outskirts
britain's acute housing crisis will not
be easily resolved
but bulldozing traditional conservative
support
was not part of the plan paul kelso sky
news in amisham